what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay this thought was
going through the comments for some of
my videos on how to kill superheroes and
one of the things that I noticed is that
a lot of you guys wanted me to make a
video on Colossus how do you cope
Colossus Rob how do you kill Colossus
well we're gonna cover that in this
video now before we start I will say it
would be easy for us to be like will
Magneto we'll just like seize control of
Colossus while he's in his metal form
and then I condensed him down to the
size of a tin can but that would not be
fun that would be boring so we are not
gonna do that
that'd be the shortest video ever had to
kill superheroes ahh magneto grabs
Colossus while he's in his metal form
and then just crushes him to death
thanks for watching guys peace that
would not be very fun that would be kind
of boring so like we always do with our
videos on CAD on how to kill superheroes
we're gonna provide a little bit of a
brief overview for those people who are
not familiar with the character of
Colossus now Colossus also known as
Peter Rasputin is basically a mutant
that hails from the former Soviet Union
where he worked as a farmer before being
recruited by Charles Xavier to join the
x-men and giant-size x-men issue number
one and 1975 now I do have videos or I
have a video actually called a Colossus
explain why his kind of run over his
history went over his powers but the
truth of the matter is that in response
to the Avengers in the United States the
Soviet Union wanted their own team
called the winter guard as they
literally just went around the entire
country and captured anybody who had
superhuman powers or the intention of
just brainwashing them the kicker was
that instead of Colossus allowing
himself to be taken Xavier showed up in
the nick of time and then he was whisked
off to join the x-men but what I also
want to talk about is what makes
Colossus so difficult to kill so
Colossus mutant powers basically grant
him the ability to transform his skin
into an organic metal steel that makes
him virtually impervious to physical
damage now the reason why we say organic
metal is because we don't really know
exactly what is composed of there's
theories where it's like iron or
something else but it seems to be unique
wholly to him now while in his organic
metal form Colossus possesses
super-strength and also does not require
food water or oxygen to survive
furthermore when Colossus transforms
into his steel form he
around one foot of height bringing him
to about seven feet tall and doubles his
weight from 250 to 500 pounds now in
addition to strength durability and
stature Colossus is also an expert
hand-to-hand combatant having been
trained by both Wolverine and Cyclops as
well as being trained in gymnastics by
Nightcrawler which kind of increases his
agility to complement his superhuman
strength now in addition to all of this
throughout Colossus lengthy history
we've seen him go toe-to-toe with some
of the hardest hitters in Marvel Comics
and come out unscathed some of these
opponents include juggernaut Qi hawk and
the blob and in fact when Colossus
encounters world war hulk although we do
end up seeing what where Hulk apply
enough force to basically break Colossus
his arms while he's in his metal form
Hulk does say that Colossus would make
for an imposing challenge if it was not
well breaker Hulk and just regular
Incredible Hulk basically now to get a
sense of just how durable Colossus is we
can essentially look at some of the
incredible feats and durability that
he's displayed for instance he's taken
several punches from opponents with
super-strength like gladiator from the
Shiar empire juggernaut and world war
hulk himself in each of these instances
Colossus is able to continue fighting
through multiple blows before being
incapacitated however he is ultimately
defeated each time but not before
putting up a pretty respectable fight
and in none of these instances does he
sustain any lasting physical damage as
well it is possible to overcome his
durability and injure him with a
physical attack the number of people who
can actually do this can only really be
counted on one hand now if we assume
that we don't possess the strength to
kill Colossus in his armor form it makes
sense to shift our attention to ways
that we can basically force him out of
his armor form and into his normal human
form
now while Colossus is still extremely
strong by normal human standards in his
normal human form his durability is
drastically reduced and so what this
does is basically removed the biggest
obstacle and killing him now one way we
know of forcing Colossus out of his
armor form is to expose him to vibranium
now for those of you guys who are not
familiar with vibranium it's basically
the fourth strongest metal in the Marvel
Universe coming after the material that
makes up Captain America's shield true
vibranium an uber metal which is the
material that makes up Forrest hammer
but there's actually two types of
vibranium in the Marvel Universe
there's anti metal or Antarctic
vibranium which vibrates at a way
length that actually breaks the
molecular bonds of other metals and then
there's wakandan vibranium which is able
to absorb vibrations and kinetic energy
now in the fourth issue of a miniseries
titled
x-men spider-man in 2008 we saw Colossus
being attacked by a clone of Kraven the
hunter that was engineered by mr.
sinister using the DNA of Kraven himself
and the original x-men now the clone
does attack Colossus for the blade that
simply described as being vibranium in
nature but due to the properties that
the blade exhibits we can infer that
this is the anti metal form of Antarctic
vibranium because it causes Colossus
skin to instinctively revert back to its
human form from its armored form which
allows for Colossus to be cut by the
blade itself and so it seems like the
easiest way to kill Colossus would
simply be to acquire vibranium from the
Antarctic region and then use it on
Colossus the problem is that this is
exceedingly rare and very difficult to
do however there is possibly another way
to kill Colossus without having to
confront his physical attributes at all
by exploiting his emotional connections
one of the most consistent personality
traits that we see in Colossus is as
deep loyalty to those that he cares
about especially as it relates to two
people his younger sister Illyana
Rasputin also known as magic and his
former girlfriend
Kitty Pryde historically throughout his
publication history Colossus care so
deeply for his sister and Kitty that if
either of them are put in danger he'll
do whatever it takes to keep them from
harm and so if someone were able to
place either of these two in a situation
of imminent danger and then demand the
Colossus revert back to his unarmored
form that may work but it would have to
be done in a way that he could be killed
before having a chance to rescue either
of them or defeat his captor and so
while this method may not be the most
efficient way of killing him it is
possible something else to note here
though is that Colossus has actually
died in Marvel Marvel Comics this was
done in a story where he basically
sacrificed his life by taking the cure
for the legacy virus a disease that went
through and was basically killing
mutants everywhere now the reason why I
did this is because a cure was developed
by beast but the only way for the Cure
to go airborne and cure everybody who
was infected with the legacy virus was
for a mutant to take it and then die
allowing the cure to go airborne and so
because this Colossus basically was
killed off now he did come back in
astonishing x-men but with all that said
I have also read some statements during
my research that Colossus
although resistant to extreme
temperatures can be vulnerable to
extreme heating followed by rapid
cooldown but I have not been able to
find any evidence to indicate this and
come in the form it doesn't mean that
it's not out there it simply means that
I haven't been able to locate it and so
if any of you guys out there know or
have a source that you can link me to to
verify that then I'll go ahead and post
that error I guess I'll I'll pin that in
the comment section so everybody knows
that's a legitimate way to kill his
character but again Colossus is a tough
nut to crack
I mean he's a tough guys it's not easy
to kill him because he is so incredibly
durable I mean he's withstood tanks he's
withstood atomic explosions I mean he's
a wildly difficult guy to kill but again
his durability isn't limitless and his
arms being broken things like that I
mean there was a story where magneto
basically forced him out of his metal
form using his powers over magnetism but
again magneto seems like too easy of an
answer for how to kill Colossus I mean
that's the surefire way to kill him just
have magneto kill but it's just too easy
I want to go for something a little more
difficult here but if you guys are new
to comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later
[Music]